bienvenue à part l autochtone et si
c'est melissa maulin dupuis cette
semaine j'ai reçu une question de
philippe qui me demande qu'est ce qui
fait que certaines communautés
autochtones réussissent à transmettre
leur langue tandis que d'autres la perde
une raison pourquoi on a perdu notre
langue vraiment à faire avec les
pensionnats le fait que dans les écoles
dans les pensionnats on se faisait
disputer voir battre parce qu'on parle
notre langue
aujourd'hui c'est plus censé exister
quoi qu'il ya des fois des que
d'enseignants qui chicane les élèves
parce qu'il parle dans leur langue mais
ce soit dans les écoles non autochtone
mais dans les écoles autochtones dans
les communautés on essaie vraiment de
financer le plus possible les courts
d'avoir des approches traditionnelles
c'est à dire d'avoir des cours qui sont
à l'extérieur et ça ça a vraiment
raviver la flamme de la langue des
premières nations
un des enjeux par exemple qui est pas à
la portée des écoles se dit à quel point
aussi la langue française et anglaise
est omniprésente dans tous les aspects
de la vie
les études la télévision les médias
youtube
toutes ces aspects là on n'est pas quand
même très directe c'est-à-dire la partie
que tu vois à l'école puis la partie où
tu vis dans la société
c'est quand même quelque chose qui va
avoir un impact
certaines nations ont malheureusement eu
des contacts beaucoup plus longtemps est
beaucoup plus proche avec les non
autochtones et certaines communautés
c'est très nations ont réussi par leur
éloignement à conserver intact dans
toute la communauté la langue donc
l'éloignement de certains gagnent
ensemble a beaucoup bénéficié aux
langues mais aussi le fait que les aînés
ont resté actif alors dans la langue ont
réussi à continuer à parler avec les
jeunes soient aussi ça le regarde et ça
extrêmement envie cependant on n'a pas
la télévision en innu on a du québec ou
en as capi continuellement que je pense
à la pdn où il ya beaucoup de programmes
qui sont dans les langues
traduit dans les langues sous titré un
orient mais malheureusement ils doivent
se partager une programmation qui est
pas toujours une toujours à chaque
nation le même temps d'antenne moi je
sais que pour avoir appris l'anglais en
écoutant la télévision je ne doute pas
du pouvoir des médias par rapport à
l'enseignement qu'on en fait cependant
aujourd'hui on voit qu'un os de
financement par rapport aux programmes
de langue autochtone il ya des centres
d'amitié je pense juste à montréal est
un élément qui donne les cours des onze
langues qui sont présentes au québec
avec des enseignants qu'ils parlent leur
langue couramment donc c'est quand même
un service qui était pas accès c'est
votre foi et qui aujourd'hui bénéficie
non seulement à aux communautés
autochtones en milieu urbain mais aussi
aux non autochtone qui ont décidé
d'apprendre des langues autochtones et
ça je peux dire que ça l'est un impact
quand on voit justement des politiciens
qui apprennent le cas niang erreur ou
qui vont vouloir saluer les gens dans la
langue autochtone c'est-à-dire ont
revalorisé l'anglais et on les finance
surtout ça c'est très important de
financer les programmes de langues et je
pense qu'en garde entre activement en
vue on va regagner moi je sais que je
regagne plus que j'en perds dans les
dernières décennies
donc ça me donne beaucoup de raisons
d'être encouragée et j'ai vraiment
l'intention que mes enfants sont aussi
apprendre la langue
donc merci pour la question philippe
j'espère y avoir répondu j'espère que
vous allez pas hésité à nous en envoyer
d'autres avalent autochtone bonne
semaine